can't promise
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when does it start any minute now
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
open sesame
good morning Unity 22 welcome to
Spaceport please sign in to the
astronaut logbook
the names Branson Sir Sir Richard
Branson
astronaut double o one license
the thrill
astronaut002 Beth Moses
astronaut003 Colin Bennett
astronaut004 sarisha Bella
zero zero
congratulations Unity 22 you are
officially registered for space
foreign
way to start off your journey first on a
bike and now on a spaceship the team is
Airborne here's some footage of them
taking off just moments ago
the space flight system was towed out to
the runway and elegantly took to the
skies on what is a beautiful morning
here in the state of New Mexico they're
at approximately 30 000 feet in altitude
and climbing as we speak our space
flight system is comprised of two
vehicles in a mated configuration
our Mothership Eve named thoughtfully by
Richard after his late mother Eve and
spaceship Unity named by the late
Stephen Hawking as a vehicle that will
unite the world through space
once at the launch altitude and location
Evil release Unity for a voyage to space
so today is the day everyone Chris what
is the significance of today's flight
yeah I love it when the stuff of dreams
becomes a reality and we've been
dreaming of of commercial space flight
of people being able to fly in space I
mean since the very first pioneer
started flying the X-15 which was the
wonderful program in the 60s was so much
like the profile that they're going to
follow today and then the Ansari X prize
to try and push the limits that that is
very much the the DNA that's that's on
this bottle in fact the DNA that has
allowed this vehicle to fly and it is
like all of those pioneers and the the
flight today uh you know they they pried
the door open initially but this crew
today is really pushing it open
permanently and I'm really excited for
the flight but I think it's so
significant professionally technically
but personally for the people on board
absolutely and you mentioned opening up
that doorway Kelly you're one of the
people that's going to be going through
that doorway soon we are so thrilled to
have you here to get a preview of what
you're going to experience on a Virgin
Galactic mission in the not too distant
future you've got to be getting pretty
excited right incredibly excited you
know this is an emotional day right
those doors are opening for the next
generation of astronauts I feel like we
have front row seats to the final
frontier today and I'm so excited to get
a taste of what I'm going to experience
soon
definitely well I'm so thrilled to have
you here and you too Chris thank you
guys so much for joining me today for
this let's take a look at what we've got
in store for the live stream
so while Mothership Eve is transporting
spaceship Unity to the launch point
we'll check in with the crew and the
preparations that went into today's
flight
we'll also share some perspective on the
Virgin Galactic Mission so who we are
what we do and our vision for commercial
space travel in the 21st century
next we'll give you a guided tour
through the Virgin Galactic experience
showing you what our astronauts will see
and do throughout their stay both on the
ground and on their life-changing
journey into space
once we've reached the launch altitude
and location we'll see the moment when
spaceship Unity is released from
Mothership Eve and accelerates into
space all coming to you live
so there's some incredible Energy
building here at Spaceport and we're
happy to have some special guests on
site taking in this experience my
co-host Kevin Prieto a procurement
specialist here at Virgin Galactic is
downstairs right now Kevin what's the
vibe like down there
thanks Veronica I am currently here at
Spaceport America's Hangar floor where
the ships usually reside but as you just
saw they're on their way to space right
behind me I have the Rocket Motors we
use for launch and to my left a very
important person CEO of Virgin Galactic
Michael Cole Glazer Michael good to see
you it's great to be here Kevin Michael
I have one question for you and that is
what does today mean
Kevin this is a landmark moment for
Virgin Galactic it's a landmark moment
for the new commercial space industry
and it certainly is a landmark moment
for our founder so Richard Branson who
right now is showing that when you have
the fortitude to follow your dream you
can make a hugely profound impact on the
world
it's a historic moment because today we
are endeavoring to open access to space
for all can you imagine being up there
and looking back down has to be one of
the most amazing feelings and we can't
wait for more people to experience it
I have to say how proud I am Kevin
to have all my friends and colleagues
who are today's crew representing the
entire company
they're opening the door for the
astronauts of tomorrow
we're thrilled to be here today and so
excited to have all of you watching to
be sharing this moment with us
it sure really is a historical moment
for us and I'm excited to be here I'm
going to be out in the street so
make space itself more accessible and
approachable
foreign
have you ever thought about going
through into space Richard
um
[Music]
the moon landing was a catalystic moment
for me I remember my dad taking me
outside onto the Village Green and we
just looked up at the Moon I really did
think that myself and many other young
people would one day be able to go into
space
I waited and I waited and waited for
that opportunity and it never came
they got me thinking
I went to the registry office and I
registered the name Virgin Galactic
Airways it's a brilliant Innovation
Story the origins of space flight at the
time it was big government the X prize
was a chance to turn that into a much
more personal space flight experience
spaceship one claimed the X prize and
improved the dream as possible this was
the first private venture to go to space
return safely and do it again just two
weeks later and then from there we just
started expanding we knew we wanted a
bigger system we wanted something that
you could float about the cabin actually
experience Zero Gravity
version Galactic offers the first real
platform where we can actually open it
up to make space for all of us
we build on the shoulders of giants but
we want to be that first Baseline for
Earth and actually deliver on that
promise we are changing the way Humanity
views space
taking the impossible and we're making
it inevitable I always want to celebrate
the team on this
you need hot
you need the best Minds you need the
best humans to work on programs like
this
the sky is no longer the limit for us
this is an inflection point in human
history two astronauts on a tiny
television inspired a kid from England
imagine what greatness can come from a
generation seen Earth from space
you're seeing your home planet
it's a real connection with the Earth it
grounds you and it feels timeless
I think in the same way that I was
inspired by the moon landing release
I really hope that there will be
millions of kids all over the world who
will be captivated and inspired about
the possibility of them going to space
one day
[Music]
have you ever thought about going to
into space Richard
I'd love to go into space I think there
have been there could be nothing nicer
so if you're building a spacecraft I'd
love to come with you on it
[Music]
foreign
inspirational and right now all of that
inspiration is up in the sky as the
Virgin Galactic space flight Mission
makes its way towards the launch Point
let's take a look at these onboard
camera footages now and see what we've
got here we are already at 40 000 feet
you can already see the incredible View
and the Sky starting to darken there
this is already higher than what most
regular commercial airliners will travel
at so I'm sure all of our astronauts are
taking in that view already and getting
really excited and prepared for the
mission
now Kelly we hope to connect live with
Richard throughout the show here what
would be going through your mind if you
were on board with him right now gosh
you know aside from the overwhelming
excitement right I think it would just
be a sense of awe the hard work and the
vision that it took to get to today and
the magnitude of what it means for the
next generation of humans who are going
to experience The Wonder of space flight
absolutely I mean this is certainly the
dawn of a new space age and Mothership
Eve is currently ascending still we're
already over 40 000 feet our Target
launch altitude for today is 45 000 feet
but in addition to that launch altitude
we also have a designated release Point
within the airspace so while you may see
us get to altitude rather quickly we'll
continue to complete our flight path
until we get to that designated launch
point
so everything's looking really good
again they're over 40 000 feet now in
just a beautiful view you get there
already I imagine they're just getting
really excited for their upcoming space
flight So speaking of the crew on board
let's take a look at the folks in flight
today
Virgin Galactic Pilots are without a
doubt among the very best of the best
they're some of the most experienced
pilots in the world and there are very
few flying machines on Earth or off
Earth that these professionals haven't
flown in fact four of our Pilots are
among the very few in history who can
lay claim to the title of astronaut and
two of them are heading to space again
today let's meet the crew now
we'll begin with the folks who are
supporting today's flight in the chase
plane giving us visuals on the space
flight system while airborne
pilot in command of our Chase plane
today is Jameel jinjua he's completed
over 4 000 flying hours in 48 different
Vehicles throughout his career which
spans over 20 years in the Royal
Canadian Air Force
joining Jameel is Patrick Moran who
served as a pilot in the Marine Corps
for 20 years where he operated as a test
pilot and a test pilot school instructor
he joins Virgin Galactic with over 3 000
flight hours in 34 different aircraft
in Mothership Eve today we have CJ
sturkow in the left seat CJ has
completed four NASA space shuttle
missions and two spaceship Unity space
flights he has been flying for 37 years
and is the first person to enter space
from three different states
CJ is joined by Kelly Latimer in the
right seat who's locked more than 6 700
hours in her 32-year flying career and
Kelly is also a pilot with Virgin orbit
our sister space company and she just
flew their successful launch the other
week
piloting spaceship Unity today we have
our chief pilot and Astronaut Dave Makai
Dave's been with Virgin companies for
over 25 years now and has more than 14
000 hours of flight time to his credit
just incredible and spanning no fewer
than 140 different types of aircraft
with Dave is astronaut Mike masucci Mike
recently passed more than 10 000 hours
of log flight in a career that's put him
in the cockpit of more than 80 different
types of aircraft including the U2 and
of course our very own spaceship Unity
as you can see our passengers today will
be flown to space by some of the most
accomplished and experienced pilots in
the world and in the cabin of space of
unity today there are four mission
Specialists let's hear some more about
them now
astronaut004 sarisha bandla I'll be
testing the researcher experience Virgin
Galactic is opening up the opportunity
to go to space for everyone this is a
whole new era to get people from
different backgrounds different
geographies different communities into
space and it's giving researchers the
opportunity to fly with their payloads
and that is unheard of they can take the
work that they've been doing on Earth to
space and I'm so excited to see where
the community takes it in the future
astronaut003 Colin Bennett I'll be
evaluating cabin procedures during boost
and weightlessness when I was younger I
assumed that space was only available to
a very select few I had no idea myself
that I would ever be in a position to go
to space book but here I am and how
awesome it's going to be to uh to be a
part of the the Journey of opening this
up to hundreds and then thousands of
more people in the future
astronaut zero zero two Beth Moses Alby
spaceship cabin lead and test director I
cannot remember not dreaming of going to
space this is the little tiny kid
looking up at the stars the little girl
making model rockets it is just was part
of my childhood I think it's a very
natural human innate curiosity we're all
Explorers and adventurers so I really
don't remember an age or a moment where
I discovered space I just always
remember dreaming of going to space
[Music]
I'll be evaluating the customer space
flight experience
[Music]
astronaut001 what a title to have now I
don't know about you guys but I'm
excited to hear who gets the spot of 007
as well
so let's hear more about the man who has
the License To Thrill
dear mum
you always told me to reach for the
stars
[Music]
well I took my own Winding Road
but I always knew to follow your lead
you always pushed us to our limits
when I was a child you threw me out of
the car miles from our house and urged
me to find my own way home you let me
jump into a river to sink or swim
you and dad taught me and my sister's
Independence
and loved us with fierceness and
tenderness
you were always an adventurer
you took glider lesson stressed as a boy
enlisted during World War II toured
Germany as a ballet dancer after the war
you flew treacherous routes as Intrepid
cabin crew for start-up Airlines who
took us into the great unknown on family
holidays
we're treated every day as the chance to
explore before the word existed you were
always an entrepreneur you helped make
ends meet by creating your own small
businesses
he showed me how to grow a company
how to treat people
how to be created
how to balance work and play
[Music]
how to live
you are always a romantic you and dad
showed Jonah me the way to build a life
filled with humor and hard
open humility
honesty and happiness you showed us the
value of kindness the magic of laughter
the beauty of music
and the joy of family
always my Guiding Light at Virgin
Galactic you shared with me that the day
we named our Mothership the MSE was one
of your happiest you always knew Eve
would start my journey to space one day
just as I always knew you would do the
impossible for me
well mum a Mothership which carries your
name will carry the next generation of
Dreams into space
you are always a dreamer you urged me to
strive for every opportunity I saw you
told me to Chase my wildest fantasies
and live life to the full
well the brave may not live forever for
the cautious do not live at all
how you lived how you loved
and how you are missed
that always said isn't life wonderful
and you both showed us it was
[Music]
such a beautiful letter
um Eve Branson really was an inspiration
to all of us here at Virgin Galactic
if you're just now tuning in my name is
Veronica McGowan I'm a structures
operations engineer here at Virgin
Galactic alongside me is astronaut Chris
Hadfield and future astronaut Kelly
Girardi so great to have you guys here
earlier today we saw Richard and his
crew make their way down to the
astronaut walkway at Spaceport America
seeing their families off before they
were escorted to our space flight system
where final inspections and preparations
were made before takeoff
they were driven to the runway and our
Fleet of Land Rovers and Land Rover is
our Exclusive Automotive partner and
they help with day-to-day operations and
in fact we have a bespoke vehicle that
we designed with them called the
astronaut Edition and this is
exclusively available to Virgin Galactic
future astronauts and it's the one that
drove Richard to Spaceport to stage of
unity this morning
so we're delighted to have Land Rover as
a part of the team
and right now our crew are on their way
to space let's check in on them via our
onboard camera footage
wow look at that view already and you
can see some contrails Chris how do you
think the crew will be feeling right
about now
uh so many different things at once
they're they're just about leveled off
at altitude right up at 46 000 feet
but inside their bodies they've got like
this tug of war going on because they're
focused like there's no more focused you
know the four in the back and the two in
the front really focused but at the same
time there's this like Rising excitement
that you can feel like like a
thermometer going up inside your own
body but I remember at the time what I
really wanted to do was go back to my
nine-year-old self and just run around
the cockpit and scream and wave my hands
because it's just so exciting and fun
they're focused they're professional
they're doing their job but it's just a
magnificent moment as we get ready for
ignition yeah I mean I'm sure there's
certainly a mixture of excitement and
anticipation with our crew today but
they will all be focused on the task at
hand as you said in preparing themselves
to run through their individual test
points
and on the subject of testing today's
space flight is an opportunity for us to
evaluate our cabin experience it's the
environment where our passengers will
cross the 50-mile border defined by NASA
prayers that's where the Innovations of
Virgin Galactic come in
so Henry
what does space flight with Virgin
Galactic entail well it has a unique
combination of revolutionary design
innovations that make it like no other
vehicle that has ever gone before
firstly air launch most Rockets you see
make a loud and bumpy vertical launch
from the ground to launch from the
ground requires huge amounts of energy
to lift the vehicle from a static start
and to propel it through the thickest
parts of the Earth's atmosphere instead
Virgin Galactic space flight starts with
a smooth Runway takeoff not dissimilar
to a conventional commercial airliner
the spaceship attached to a Mothership
gracefully ascends to the launch
altitude of around 50 000 feet bypassing
the thickest parts of the Earth's
atmosphere making it far more energy
efficient and far more comfortable for
the passengers inside
when the vehicles have reached the
launch altitude and location Mission
Control provides clearance for release
release the pilots activate the launch
and set spaceship free within seconds
the rocket motor ignites as the vehicle
starts its rapid Ascent toward the stars
during this awe-inspiring Journey the
spaceship reaches speeds of up to three
times the speed of sound and out the
window passengers will watch the color
change from Blue through Indigo and then
to the iconic Inky black as the soar
into space
once the rocket motor shuts down
passengers will unbuckle their seat
belts and Float effortlessly around the
cabin enjoying the childlike freedom of
zero gravity the cabin becomes a
spacious three-dimensional playground as
passengers experience space firsthand
helmet free the ship has an incredible
17 windows and passengers won't be able
to resist being drawn towards the
undeniable euphoric beauty that Lies
Beneath as planet earth looks right back
at them in all her majesty whilst
enjoying weightlessness and the
life-changing view the vehicle is
preparing itself for re-entry into the
Earth's atmosphere utilizing the second
design innovation of Virgin Galactic
space system the feather
re-entry is arguably the most
challenging aspect of space travel and
has largely been approached in two ways
with winged vehicles or with capsule
spacecraft the Revolutionary aspect of
Virgin Galactic feather technology is
that it enables the vehicle to act like
a winged vehicle when it is advantageous
to be a winged vehicle and then behave
as a capsule when a capsule design gives
you the advantage
space the spaceship folds and half with
the booms moving upward to a 60 degree
position as our Pilots put the vehicle
into an elegant backflip this points the
windows straight back towards Earth
offering passengers astounding and
unobstructed Views this maneuver also
allows the vehicle to behave like a
capsule on re-entry spread spread of
friction heat generated from re-entering
the Earth's atmosphere across the entire
underside of the spaceship and
aerodynamically enabling it to reorient
itself from any position once the ship
has slowed down and starts to travel
through the thicker parts of the Earth's
atmosphere where winged vehicle is
advantageous for maneuverability the
booms come back down from their feather
position and the spaceship gently Glides
back home safely and smoothly
ensuring a thrilling yet comfortable
ride for those on board and landing on
the same Runway it took off from
a truly extraordinary design fit for an
out of this world experience
to experience zero g and see our fragile
Planet floating in the depths of space I
will go up in a minute if my wife would
let me how about you Veronica no
absolutely I mean that would be an offer
to get to refuse now Chris I'm sure
you'd agree that the experience that
Richard is having right now is probably
a lot more comfortable than your
launches
yeah I had a chance to fly as part of
the Space Shuttle crew twice and then I
flew on the Russian ship as the pilot
once and it's a little capsule like they
were talking about winged and capsule
vehicles but both of them needed a
rocket to get them up above the
atmosphere and the beauty of what Sir
Richard and his crew are doing now is
that they've had the mothership Eve to
carry them gently up so yeah they're
much more comfortable than I was at this
stage getting ready for for the second
engine and the the Rockets to ignite
there yeah I can imagine and Kelly now I
know know you've experienced zero g
already in some parabolic flights your
space flight will surely be an extension
right of that zero g time what are you
most looking forward to in terms of
conducting experiments in that
environment yeah exactly like Veronica
said I've done a number of parabolic
research flights here on Earth where the
aircraft takes this roller coaster
profile to simulate 0g seconds at a time
but during a dedicated research Mission
with Virgin Galactic I am most looking
forward to that continuous uninterrupted
minutes worth of microgravity exposure
to do my experiments it's just an
unprecedented time the next generation
of researchers and scientists are going
to be flying with their payloads and I'm
so excited for what's to come yes
definitely excited for your space flight
and I'm very excited that people can
experience you know not only that
personal transformation on space flights
but also conduct scientific research so
it's a really flexible platform I am
here I am hearing from our mission
control center now that we are about six
and a half minutes out to release we're
getting pretty close so let's go ahead
and switch over over to our onboard
camera footage for the whole portion of
the flight here until Landing I am
hearing we're in the middle of our L
minus 10 checks and L minus 10 it means
we're approximately 10 minutes out from
the moment when Mothership Eve releases
spaceship unity and this is based on an
estimated time of arrival to that
release point so timing may vary a
little bit but the closer we get to that
point the more accurate the estimate
becomes and right now we're about six
minutes out so up until L minus 10 Eve
is in full Mothership mode carrying
spaceship Unity to altitude and
providing her you know through
essentially an umbilical cord with
electrical power system heat and cabin
pressurization and this air is
conditioned so we can keep folks cool on
the ground for hot summer days like
today and heat it at high altitudes
where things get a little bit cooler to
keep the pilots and the passengers
comfortable
so at L minus 10 spaceship Unity
switches to her own battery power for
avionics and control systems and
performs electrical checks feather
system checks flight control checks and
more
and unity and Eve have their own
intercon system throughout this so
they're communicating with each other in
the vehicles and with the mission
control center throughout each stack
each check here
you know these days more and more
systems are becoming automated
especially in aircraft and spacecraft
and what's really exciting about the
Virgin Galactic space flight system is
that our crew truly are Hands-On with
the piloting throughout the flight
oh there's Sir Richard Branson now it's
so exciting to see them in the back I'm
sure they are just getting incredibly
excited
and of course as mentioned earlier we
have Dave and Mike up front we have an
amazing team of Pilots here and you know
they just love to Pilot a vehicle that
is arguably the most exciting vehicle in
the world to fly
and I imagine you know this also
provides passengers with an additional
level of comfort knowing they have crew
members with them throughout the
duration of the flight
there they are again just moments away
at this point it's looking like we're
about four minutes and 20 seconds out
now
all right so I am hearing from our
mission control center that we have L
minus four checks in work now so we just
passed the four minute Mark at this
point the pilots are ensuring the
spaceship is in its launch configuration
after going through the various L minus
10 checks just confirming all settings
are back in their place and go for
launch
now this is also the point when
spaceship Unity will isolate her Air
Supply from Eve and prime the rocket
motor by opening the backup oxidizer
valve
and once these actions are complete the
pilots are going to seek clearance for
release from MCC
orthand for our mission control center
we have two mcc's supporting today our
primary Horizon is located here at
Spaceport America and they're being
supported by the Oculus Mission Control
Center at our manufacturing base in
Mojave California
these teams consist of experts across
various departments and disciplines
within the company and they're verifying
checks with the crew today every step of
the way
all right and I've just heard from MCC
that our L minus four checks are
complete we are roughly three minutes
out from release at this point it's
getting really exciting
I don't know about you all but I can
feel the anticipation building just
watching the screen and looking at their
faces look at that they've already got
big smiles on
and we have just received clearance for
release on time for mission control
centers so we are two minutes and 30
seconds out now
I can only imagine what it would be like
to be on board this must be incredibly
exciting for the crew
we're about two minutes out now and once
we get to the 32nd Point spaceship Unity
is going to arm the launch pylon
and then once we get to that designated
point the mothership Pilots are actually
the ones that engage the release setting
Unity free
so we have actions for both the
mothership pilots and the spaceship
Pilots so they're in coordination and
I'll agree on the launch
yeah it's a hugely exciting and focused
moment right now
definitely one minute and 30 seconds
the spaceship Pilots are also going to
push the stick all the way forward to
prepare for release
and things happen pretty quickly after
the release so the pilots are gonna
light the rocket motor and they're gonna
accelerate in level flight until they
reach Mach 1 at which point they'll
start what we call the gamma turn where
we turn directly up and head to space
one minute to release now
it's getting real
so exciting
45 seconds
30 seconds the spaceship Unity Pilots
are arming the launch pylon now
we are armed for release 20 seconds
10 seconds
five
three two one release release
clean release ignition
good rocket motor burn
there's Mach 1 trimming now
trim complete Unity is pointed directly
up and heading to space things are
looking great we are 25 seconds into the
burn now approaching Mach 2.
30 seconds Mach 2. everything's looking
really good and stable
40 seconds
45 seconds
50 seconds approaching Mach 3
there's mach3
and 60 seconds and that is a full
duration burn folks we are headed to
space
and the passengers in the back have been
cleared to unstrap our predicted apogee
is 279
000 feet and climbing
the pilots are now unlocking the feather
and um as soon as they do that it's
going to initiate a backflip for
spaceship Unity this is normal we want
those windows pointed down towards the
Earth to maximize that incredible View
so feather is coming up now and the
pilots are also enabling the RCs or
reaction control system which is what
they'll use to control the attitude of
the vehicle while we're outside the
atmosphere
all right feather is all the way up we
are at about 250 000 feet now and
climbing as soon as we cross the
boundary to space we'll hear a word from
our founder Sir Richard Branson
welcome to space Unity 22.
so it doesn't sound like we're receiving
the audio over the broadcast but I know
Richard is saying something
inspirational as he always does
fortunately we have a lot of cameras uh
recording things on board today and
we'll be sure to capture his magical
words and share them with the world when
they're available
we reached apogee 282
000 feet
remember the day remember where you are
and remember who you shared this with
and remember the name Virgin Galactic
because today space is Virgin Territory
the culmination of a life's work more
than a half a century since the world
rejoiced in and was transformed by
humans leaving planet Earth Sir Richard
Branson fulfills his long-held dream of
experiencing space with his crew
congratulations again Richard and
congratulations also to sirisha and
Colin on becoming astronauts today and
welcome back to space to Dave Mike and
Beth
oh you can see him now
so we are on the re-entry portion of our
flight now and the mission Specialists
are heading back to their seats
our training team has worked really hard
on this portion of the flight to make it
very natural and intuitive for
passengers
now when we talk about space travel a
lot of people know and expect the Boost
portion of the flight to be loud and
thrilling but what's interesting is
re-entry is also very similar as
supersonic air is flowing over the
vehicle in The Feathered configuration
shock waves form on top of the cabin
which are audible to those inside and
for those of you on site watching on the
ground you should be able to hear a
double Sonic Boom as spaceship Unity
once again breaks the sound barrier
all right folks we are now subsonic
just under 75 000 feet in altitude
now also note too this is our first time
transmitting HD camera data down to the
ground and then out to a global live
stream so please do bear with us as we
may occasionally see some drops in the
feed but we still have some really great
ground footage coming in here oh there
we go now we can see that is the tail
cone of unity
and the pilots are lowering the feather
now
as the feather comes down the nose of
spaceship is going to drop this is
normal and expected once that feathers
down and locked the pilots will begin a
gentle pull-up to a level attitude and
I'm hearing the feather is down and
locked now
so at this point spaceship Unity is a
glider so it's all about balancing her
potential and kinetic energy so if the
pilots want to go faster they point the
nose down and if they want to go slower
they bring the nose up
and right now I'm hearing the crews
listening to a special soundtrack for
The Glide it's the latest release from
Khalid a track called New Normal
and all of us will get to hear that on
Earth during our celebration so stick
around for that
I don't know about you all but I am
still feeling overwhelmed and excited
about what we just witnessed and there's
one person in particular who's got to be
having all of the feels right now you
can see him sending a congratulations
congratulatory shake to his passenger
Colin Bennett there with him
let's see if we can connect with the
crew again here
's a manual down to two
so Richard you just went to space this
has got to be the ultimate birthday
present for you
what was it like
all right folks again sorry we're we're
not getting that transmission through
the live broadcast but again we do have
lots of recording devices aboard the
spaceship and we will be sure to release
some footage of Richard and the crew up
there today
I just can't wait for
it's a complete experience for a
lifetime
and now I'm looking down at a beautiful
Spaceport
congratulations to everybody for
creating such a beautiful beautiful
place congratulations
for 17 years of hard work together this
time
all right so I'm so happy we could catch
a little part of that it seems like
there's a little bit of a delay in the
transmission there it does have a long
way to travel but you could tell by the
smiles on their faces they just had the
right of their lives we are so excited
for them to land and party the rest of
the day with like astronauts in the
typical virgin fashion
so we are at 22 000 feet now and
descending and as I mentioned earlier
Unity is a glider at this point
um so the pilots right now are
discussing their energy management plan
and pretty shortly here they'll be
meeting up with our Chase aircraft with
Jamil and Patrick to get some really
cool visuals of spaceship Unity
now as the crew and spaceship make their
way across the desert they are Gliding
Over one of the most remarkable
landscapes in the United States and the
largest desert in North America the
Chihuahuan Desert
the area around Spaceport includes more
than 6 000 square miles of restricted
airspace and high desert which is one of
the reasons it was built here
and of course our future astronauts will
be able to take in so much of that
natural beauty and you know of course we
also have a White Sands nearby White
Sands National Park is just to our East
it's visible right over the Black Range
mountains White Sands of course has been
the backdrop for so many films
commercials and music videos and it's
known for having the largest gypsum Dune
field on the planet
khalid's music
so also nearby is the Oregon Mountain
Desert Peaks National monument and
that's nearly half a million Acres of
protected land that our guest families
will be able to experience
and even though temperatures can hit the
triple digits in the summer here we also
have Cool Desert days and fortunately
our pilots and crew can stay comfortable
thanks to their spacesuits they were
designed with our technical spaceware
partner Under Armor and they're
absolutely beautiful as you can see on
the crew there they're lightweight and
made of flight grid knitted Fabrics
which forms the spacesuit and also helps
regulate their body temperature
so also to commemorate this flight from
New Mexico we reached out to the Zia
Pueblo who gave us permission to use
their Sun symbol on our spaceship
this symbol is also a part of the New
Mexico state flag and it's embedded with
symbolic meaning the number four is
sacred to the Zia people and the emblem
represents the four directions The Four
Seasons the four times of day and the
four phases of life we are honored and
proud to feature this perfectly balanced
symbol on spaceship unity's tail cone as
we also celebrate our new home
oh you can see the chase in the
background there outside of Richard's
Window
the pilots are coordinating with Chase
Now And discussing their energy
management plan they're at about 9 500
feet in altitude and the runway out here
at Spaceport America is around 4 600
feet in altitude
all right we have three landing gear
down and locked
now the pilots are going to be landing
on Runway 3-4 today so that's coming
from the south and towards the north for
those of you on site watching
and for the non-pilots tuning in those
numbers represent the first two numbers
of the magnetic heading of the runway so
for example three four is 340 degrees on
your compass
we are just about a thousand feet above
the field now and on Final
500 feet above the runway
300 feet
over the threshold
main gear touchdown
and we're going to hold it just like
this for a minute before bringing the
nose down
can see they're already celebrating
inside there
and the nose is coming down now
nose gear touchdown
and braking
look at that incredible Drone footage
here as we come in and there is full
stop
all right
A Perfect Landing Virgin Galactic has
just broken through the commercials from
our operational home base space for
America a beautiful day of flight what a
moment congratulations to everybody on
board and of course our very own
spaceship Unity who returned to space
today and of course we also saw
beautiful flying from our Eve crew CJ
and Kelly and Brilliant work by our
Chase Pilots Jamil and Patrick all of
whom are still in the air right now
great job to you all
ladies and gentlemen there it is more
than half a century since the world
rejoiced when humans first achieved
space flight Richard Branson fulfills
his dream of experiencing space travel
a special musical performance to
celebrate today's Milestone but first
let's hear some thoughts on the flight
Chris you've returned from space several
times now both on a capsule and a space
shuttle how does this Landing compare to
the landings you've experienced well
obviously that that's a much more gentle
Landing than a capsule on my soyuz
flight the shuttle two times is quite
similar to what the crew just went
through but for them of course it's such
a personal experience now and and what
are they going to do with this how are
they going to take this amazing view of
the earth that they've just had and the
the the kind of Brave New nature of what
this whole team has just accomplished
how are they going to now make that part
of who they are and how are they going
to share this experience with other
people you know that's what's going
through their minds right now I'm just
so proud of the whole team that was an
amazing accomplishment it was at thick
and you know as somebody who has spent
what like 4 000 hours in space is it
yeah how do you feel about you know a
space line for the Earth opening it's
it's what uh what I've been hoping that
we've been able to do ever since I was a
little kid dreaming about it and and
during Myspace flights so that the
technology gets good enough and someone
has the tenacity and the vision to push
beyond all the resistance of the
naysayers and to create a capability for
you don't have to be a professional
astronaut for your whole life to see the
world this way I think I mean I I just
couldn't be more proud of all the people
that work at Virgin Galactic and I'm
just so delighted at what this Open Door
is going to lead to now it's a great
moment absolutely certainly and Kelly I
want to hear your thoughts too and you
know also your daughter Delta V who is
on site today is also she's only three
and she's also a huge space Enthusiast
just like you
um and you know how does this this
Milestone affect her and mean what does
that mean for her and also for you yeah
I am still emotional from this flight it
is so amazing that a dry eye in the
studio but you know when I think of my
daughter on site just like you said it's
like this is what it's all about you
know it means the world to me but not
only that she was here to witness
history today but that she's going to
watch me her mom become an astronaut you
know that's going to be normal in her
mind that's just another thing moms do
of course they go to space you know and
I just think that's incredible she's
going to grow up knowing that not even
the sky is a limit and I think the the
other thing that struck me is it's just
such a powerful reminder of how much can
change in a single generation my mom is
also on site here today she's going to
kill me for aging her but when she was
born human beings hadn't yet been to
space and when she is growing up women
were ineligible and now here she is
watching her daughter prepare for a
space flight of my own you know it just
it gives me so much hope and excitement
for the next generation and Virgin
Galactic is just leading the way
absolutely you know and the moon landing
is what inspired Sir Richard Branson and
so who knows what you know Delta V
watching today what that's going to
inspire her to do and other people and
her generation it's so incredibly
exciting and folks this is just the
beginning Virgin Galactic is a venture
as a capital a catalyst it's the start
of a whole new space age which is
completely different from the one before
you know space was something that was
unattainable by all but a very small
group of people and it was The Preserve
of government agencies for national
pride and this is totally different you
know it's uh it's the new space age
which is you know for Kelly for Delta V
for Chris for me it's for everybody and
you know we're making it more accessible
to the public so I know you know the
full effect of what happened today will
not be felt for some time but it will
touch many generations to come
now Chris you are aboard the ISS for
about five months at one point right did
the view out the window ever get old
gosh no uh at the end of my five months
on the space station we were getting
back into our ship just sort of like the
crew returned today and just before I
got into my spacesuit I went over to the
window just to try and soak up a little
more of that incredible perspective you
know the world is so generously
beautiful and and you see it in a whole
new way you can see for thousands of
miles in each direction and you can see
the curvature of our planet and the
reality of where we all live suddenly
becomes part of who you are and right up
to the last second I you know I was
there at with my nose print on the glass
you know trying to trying to not miss
the magnificence of this entire
experience
yeah and you took like thousands of
photos up there too right I mean does
that even give you a glimpse of what it
was like as a reminder to be up there I
know the video today was a little
glitchy but we've got all the recorders
on board yes absolutely crew is going to
have now of course is their own personal
memories and then the the way to sort of
catalyze them again and be able to watch
those videos and think about uh of the
the beauty of what they've been through
and and let it sort of sink into who
they are and and so yeah I took
thousands and thousands of pictures and
videos in space and they really helped
me now remember the richness of the
experience so it'll be great to see the
videos that they recorded on board apps
absolutely and you know that richness
sticks with you too and you have a TED
Talk actually that you talked about
um well a lot of things right overcoming
fear walking through spiderwebs
um but also you know my favorite part of
it was when you talked about seeing
Earth from above and the transformation
that it has on people you know we call
it the overview effect that you know I
really hope and I'm sure that our
astronauts today experience what was
that like for you
yeah I've been so lucky to see the world
from that point of view and as one of
the very first human beings to have the
responsibility and the privilege of
being up there and and to have a vehicle
like virgin just put up today that that
is allowing more eyes than just my two
to see it to to understand not just the
geology of the world but but us on it
you know all seven billion of us and you
know we're we're on board this little
spaceship of Earth and you can actually
get a a palpable sense of that from on
board the ship and uh the crew of of you
know Unity their 20-second flight here
today
um they now have that inside of them and
all the subsequent Crews Kelly when you
fly as well you're gonna have a chance
to sort of shift your permanent
perspective of how all this works go
from being a two-dimensional human to
now suddenly really understanding the
three dimensions and what this planet
truly looks like and and it's it's going
to do us all good as many people can see
that as possible
absolutely and you know I know you're
going to be conducting a spearmints on
board while you fly with Virgin active I
hope
I hope in time to look out the
Apple too right I'm gonna have to
carefully choreograph precious time at
that window just to soak it in and enjoy
the moment and be in the moment
definitely and you know while we're
waiting for our crew to disembark now
can you actually tell us a little bit
about your experiments yeah absolutely
so I'm going to be flying Healthcare and
fluid experiments on board my research
play the first one is the Astro skin
it's a wearable sensor system designed
to monitor how space flight affects the
human body the cool thing about it is
the Astro skin is currently worn on
board the International Space Station by
astronauts but my flight will be the
first time that we're collecting data
during launch re-entry and Landing so
I'm really excited to contribute to some
novel data collection for the next
generation of astronauts another
experiment on flying is a fluid
experiment designed to evaluate the
behavior of liquid in a confined
environment in microgravity that's also
going to be fun because I'm going to be
interacting with a fluid cell that has a
camera attached to it and data collected
from that experiment can help inform you
know new technologies related to life
support systems or novel designs for
syringes for administering medicine in
space so I'm very excited for the
opportunity to take my payloads with me
to space absolutely well that's so cool
I am hearing that our our chief medical
officer Tara Castleberry is approaching
the vehicle now and they're going to do
a medical debrief with the crew so we'll
see that here momentarily and our crew
is actually going to join us later in
the broadcast where they will receive
their astronaut wings so Chris I'm sure
you have a vivid memory of the day you
received your wings
you have wings that we wear in our chest
they're a measure of of a lifetime of
work and purpose and and personal
accomplishment and all of the different
organizations of course have their own
wings but when I flew in space it was
the very first time a Canadian pilot had
flown a spaceship and so my country
designed astronaut Wings specifically
for me and it was the leader of my
country my prime minister in fact that
that put the wings on my chest so uh
that that was a huge honor for me to
have you know the prime minister of
Canada to take these new wings that had
minted to show a new human
accomplishment and then for me to have
that as part of who I am for the rest of
my life and so it's a huge honor for me
that that I'm going to be part of that
ceremony for these folks that just flew
I was just gonna say now you get to
return that honor to the crew today and
it's so exciting I know you have a
really important role to help present
those astronaut wings so we're all
looking forward to seeing that as our
pilots and passengers prepare to make
their way back to to Spaceport let's
hear a little bit more about our special
musical guest who will celebrate their
arrival